hello everyone and welcome to yet
another live here on the channel I'm
Lizzy daily your host for today if you
were here last time welcome back you are
not gonna want to miss this next live
with our very special guest today but if
you're new around here hello I'm a
wildlife biologist and a wildlife TV
presenter from the beautiful UK here
today's Sun is on our side and for a
good reason because um we have a really
exciting live coming up and for those
who didn't know it's international snake
day today so happy international sick
day and we thought we'd celebrate it by
talking about venom I mean what better
way to celebrate today and we're gonna
be learning all about venomous species
and chatting to an expert probably is
one of the most accomplished when it
comes to looking at some of the world's
most venomous and deadly species from
across the world now remember and please
do get your questions in to us live I
want to hear from you tell me about you
must be a favorite venomous snake
favorite venomous species perhaps you've
had an encounter with a venomous species
in the wild I'll always remember last
year when I was in the primary
rainforest of Borneo coming face to face
with this nocturnal beautiful primates
thus no llores now don't be fooled by
this fantastic big nocturnal eyes the
slow loris is actually the world's only
venomous primate is also one of the most
primitive primates and but actually it
secretes toxins in its upper arm and
you'll often see them kind of licking
their armpits which when mixed with
saliva or that those toxins basically
can cause a really severe allergic
reaction and they actually end up
coating their young in this saliva to
protect them from predators I mean venom
has so many capabilities and we have
lots of different types of venom in the
animal kingdom which we're going to be
learning about today so exciting so I'm
not an expert someone who is an expert
on this is biomedical scientists Alton
to catch now he really has been
everywhere studying venomous species
across the world but really what he does
is he looks at the genetic blueprint of
these toxins and essentially build up a
library of this and uses it to implies
it
to actually looking at medicines novel
medicines I mean how incredible is that
and so he doesn't just get home
face-to-face with the world's most
deadly and venomous species but he as a
scientist he then takes all this
understanding of this venom and these
toxins and applies it to real-world
applications that involves every single
one of us watching here today and he has
crossed the world spent in Sahara to
Micronesia you see videos of him
everywhere you know deep under the water
finding venomous snakes everywhere he
has been and he's actually here with us
live right now so Zoltan welcome is so
good to have you on good afternoon thank
you very much sleazy you I mean just
reading about you so you've done so much
and of course I missed there you're a
National Geographic Explorer as well you
know you ran ound in your field but as
Alton I have to ask you why venom
I mean why miss species is that a silly
question well I just follow my childhood
passion actually I'm in Hungary right
now
I'm a Hungarian and I born here and the
first venomous snakes I ever caught in
my life was just a few kilometers from
here back long long time ago I was a
high school student the first year of
the high school and I'm just fascinated
about nature unfastening about the
beauty and unknown in nature so this is
drives me this is drives me into science
and into exploration I find it beautiful
and and very rewarding and so so for you
I mean you've literally traveled the
world and come face-to-face with many
different venomous species but um let's
what you talk about what will venom is
people have a perception of venom but
but why is it so important
well what let's start it why this is so
important some of the top medications in
the world used by every major hospital
are coming from Venom's out of the top
three medications used for the most
lethal types of heart attacks two of
them are coming from snake venom one of
the most often prescribed medication
used by 40 million patients all over the
world coming from snake venom one of a
leading group of
medicines used for diabetes coming from
a lizard venom so they're really very
major medications lifesavers little
lifesavers and and so why this is
happening there are hundred and fifty
thousand venomous animal species in
earth snakes spiders a jellyfish or
chorus insects and lots of them all over
the planet they have 20 million toxins
combined 20 million toxins most of them
are studied by science
so why I have so many toxins because
evolution made Venom's into this
venomous animals to kill a prey or
predator in less than one minute
venom toxin Stokes's are the components
of the venom are the only molecules in
the entire universe designed by nature
to take a life in less than one minute
so how do I do that they target very
important parts of the human body or the
other animal bodies like nervous system
circulation the same targets what you
have to take under control in order to
treat diseases so that's why there's
such a good template's niche nature
evolution perfect at them for millions
of years that target Vita vital
receptors in the human body and they are
very precision binders defined with high
affinity and very selective so it's
really it's a goldmine for medicine yeah
and it sounds like such a big failed and
I definitely want to come on to you
later on a little bit more about what
you do in the lab but kind of bring it
back down to it I mean it's
international snake day so happy
international snake day and you let me
ask you what deadly snakes have you
worked with oh I should say venomous
snakes have you worked with well that's
the highest school kid I started to
catch vipers right here in in the middle
of Hungary then I moved to to down to
Bulgaria in a summer vocation for water
catching wipers there and then I get
bald I went to the US you know get my
first rattlesnakes in the in the western
US and then I moved to Vietnam I mean
went to Vietnam and Africa
and so I seen everything from sea snakes
to rattlesnakes from black mambas to
desert vipers
I like them all so where is snakes the
kind of the species that you work with
the most or you mentioned the you know
jelly jelly fish obviously venomous but
venom comes in many different forms
across different groups so like for you
what are you most passionate about which
group well there's not a single group
which I'm really passionate about
because you know for science we focus on
those venomous animals and I mentioned
there are a hundred and fifty thousand
different species there's a huge arsenal
we focus on those species which have a
particular type of toxins which we can
use to target that particular receptor
in the human body which is important to
treat a disease so let's say I'm telling
you an example right now we had a major
project on on scorpion Venom's
which target autoimmune disorders or
scorpion venom which target cancer so
we're looking for those kind of monomers
Animas which have this kind of toxins
blocking potassium channels or target
receptors or cells involved in cancer
treatment Wow
yeah so I mean this real world
applications is absolutely incredible
and of course this research that you do
takes you all over the world so tell us
about some of your most memorable
expeditions that you've been on well
there are many you know so I've been to
198 countries and before I'm getting
there I just have to point out that I
mentioned how major lifesavers could be
the snake Venom's and other Venom's from
animal species but on the other hand
they're also one of the deadliest
creatures on earth so their snake bites
they kill a hundred thousand people
around the globe each year 100,000
people die from snakebite every year and
they die because they cannot afford
anti-venom we have the perfect
technology and knowledge to how it will
make anti-venom but it just you know for
from financial reasons
you know most of what
tropical regions you know where snake
bites are peaking they cannot afford
anti-venom so this is really live savers
and also some of the deadliest toxins at
the same time and I have to be careful
as I'm searching for these snakes
because of course I can be bitten and
I've been bitten a number of times and
those oral defaults
yes unfortunately and so so this is sort
of the settings when we go into the
adventures in the field so in order to
go to the field first of all we have to
decide what kind of toxins to be looking
for and where are we going so we try to
time or presence in the field normally
at the starting of the rainy seasons
when you see the highest amount of
activity in venomous animals or we don't
want to go in the middle of the winter
because too cold or in the middle of the
summer is too hot and so once in a
location I love to team up with local
people local tribes like in Congo the
bark of pygmies
they need me what I do if elephants are
coming in the rainforest in the middle
of night you know so what you do you
hear the elephants trumpeting you just
run and you hide in the buttresses of
the trees the possibly behalf of my size
you know I'm an alien
so being sort of fighting you know for
the the hiding place in the buttresses
of the tree in the middle of the night
in the Congo rainforest it have to be
careful because a colleague of mine
actually died in that spot or you know
from an elephant attack they also told
me how I can get water from Lions in the
in the middle of the rainforest you just
cut it you know and and then you can
drink it okay what you do to get water
sorry to to to and proof your home so
keep the ends away you throw a sh all
around now I sleep normally in a hammock
so what I do i do my fire you know it's
a kitchen you know it's very easy in
there in the rain for us to remodel if
you don't like it you just put it a
couple of meters away and then you I
collect ash and I throw it on the trunk
of the tree
so it completely stops the ants from
coming and I learned this run from the
bark of pygmies so
laughs to team up with local people
because there can teach you so much
knowledge like in Pakistan snake
charmers can told me that it's important
take a kid to them and say what this kid
was bitten by a snake is it venomous or
not do you know what they do they get
their knife they make a cut across the
the bite mark Fang marks and they keep
the blood between their fingertips one
two three then their part is if it's
sticky and gummy then it falls from a
venomous snake if it's not that is from
a non-venomous snake and I said wow this
is interesting
they just explained me that the snake
venom the viper venom makes the blood to
coagulate two o'clock so I love to team
up with local people so again we have to
get there in the right place the right
season I make friends with local tribes
and then I set up my campsite as I
mentioned I normally sleep in a hammock
it's yeah the easiest to put it up and
you know what's the biggest danger in
the rainforest so on the biggest
venomous species or the falling tree
branches so you have to put up your hand
look but not nothing gonna fall in your
head which is actually good I was just
gonna ask use all that because I mean
this is incredible I'm sure many people
watching at your site this is amazing
what you do you kind of integrate
yourself in these environments but let's
say you head to environment with the
idea of finding a particular species how
do you go about doing that I'm heading
into the environment or how do you how
do you actually find that species
specifically and then how would you go
about actually learning about that
species venom and those toxins okay so
there's no magic bullet so there's no
guarantee sometimes I mean their
location in the Sahara or in Congo or in
Amazon and I've send that week or two
and we don't find that snake sometimes
be lucky in Amazon you know we find a
Bushmaster like a two point four meter
eight feet long Bushmaster and actually
to put in a bag snake just shoot out
like a rocket so it was a good warning
sign to me that Zoltan you still have
stuff to learn you know I'm stealing Ana
learning curve so so there is no
guarantee that we're gonna find that
snake so basically you just start to
look like the middle Viper leaves in a
place like you know this displaying
Hungarian Plains in next to the Hungary
national parks around me or you just
have to keep looking like if I looking
for sea snakes I go to a location I go
to the Pacific Ocean or I go Indian
Ocean or Panama a higher fishing man you
know with the boat and I say I'm gonna
look for a fishing SSE snake and then he
thinks I'm completely crazy but when I
actually sees me to jump from the boat
for the snake day is actually convinced
that I'm crazy so and I mobilized their
village I normally tell I team up with
local hunters and wildlife officer
scientists and I sort of mobilize the
whole village and say guys if anybody
spots a venomous creature yeah if we
look for scorpions that's much easier
because all you have to do you just
reach on the UV light and if you don't
Scott don't like scorpions don't take UV
light to the desert because you're gonna
be very disappointed so like you go to
the Sahara
you know I switch on the UV light and I
just pick up the school in one night you
can pick up easily like 20 30 or more
it's just such a fascinating place I
took off my shoes you know that was
their last time in I think November and
I said okay I'm just relaxing so I was
just walking in this is where Algeria
neasha and Libya meet with each other
go kill yourself in light time I enjoyed
myself a lot picking out the scorpions
next morning I slept there right in the
middle of the nowhere
next morning I go for a walk and I just
see the sand Viper tracks right next
from my camp so I'd say well it's good I
was lucky that you know I didn't step on
one of these 10 Vipers walking around me
yeah let's put that down to you being
biomedical scientists with a lot of
experience so I mean you
mentioned your habitat and the fact that
this is where it all started tell me
about where you are at the moment it
looks fantastic so this is interesting
and you mentioned this is the
international snake day so one one of
the most endangered subspecies of
venomous snakes leaves right here yeah
the middle wiper that's the species and
there's a subspecies or which is only
found in this geographical region in
Hungary and a couple of places
immediately surroundings this is where
it leaves so it's and unfortunately the
biggest threat to venomous creatures and
other animals in general or the habitat
destruction I mentioned a lot nature and
there are 150,000 animal species 20
million toxins we discussed us this one
depends on a healthy biodiversity and if
we destroy these habitats we wipe out
this species and this potential to
develop new medications so yeah it's
good there's a hunger National Park here
which protects the Viper and hopefully
it will be surviving here for many many
generations yeah and I guess I mean you
were talking about the fact that you
first caught it when you ate you know 14
years old so in your lifetime even I'm
sure you've seen big changes but yeah I
mean what an incredible snake species to
have on your doorstep it's just such a
shame that we're seeing this obviously
with a lot of our species but hey I'm am
I right in saying you potentially may
and a meadow Viper with you oh yeah I
can show you oh my god yeah
that'd be fantastic so okay just give me
a second I will be here no problem for
everyone still watching you can see now
a meadow I put on screen beautiful
beautiful snake and that's all son has
life that's what we do here on the
channel we get live so this is the
middle raipur Wow
it's a quite small snake and you see
that six leg band on on the back is
minimus
so I can't afford to get bitten I've
been bitten by this species before I'm
all adjectives the snake venom and today
snake anti-venom so I'm not in a good
position to get bitten here but this is
the middle whopper so and and what you
what you look right now is as I
mentioned one of the most endangered
snake in the whole world and my
colleagues and friends here just next
door they're a breeding facility where
they actually breed these snakes and
they they're released to the wild just
to try to maintain the population with
Atmos asthma as much support as possible
so sorry just to go over you're allergic
to the anti-venom I'm allergic to the
snake venom and snake anti-venom so good
position to be a snake venom reserve
holding a meadow right there right now
but nevertheless I've absolute lucia has
to say and and snakes at home actually
when I grow up there were three people
in Hungary who had permits because the
snake is a protected species three
people had a permit to keep this snake
and I was one of them of course
absolutely
it's a very nice snake and it's this is
the habitat if there's a Hungarian plane
this is untouched here and and I wish
you know most of that bird
wildlife would I mean the wilderness
would be so untouched us us right here
yeah and for those who are watching that
may not know too much about vipers what
kind of habit where would you actually
find these Vipers I'm guessing either
basking out in the Sun or and kind of
stones or sheets things like that yeah
that's correct that they like the Sun so
the first snake as I mentioned was was I
back in a long time ago it's in the 1983
first of me or second of me like in the
beginning of ma there was this
international workers day or whatever
you know holidays so I said it's a good
excuse to come to their field and look
for wipers and we get lucky
so you find this snake or in the habitat
around me and you just keep going and if
you alone your chances are lower and if
you have a couple of friends or
colleagues then you sort of form a line
and and you go in and then you know when
you ya see one then you just scream
snake and everybody ronster
it's it's it's it's it's a very nice
feeling to find find a snake and I find
them absolutely beautiful and what we do
with these snakes are not just a middle
Viper but you know in the generality
venomous snakes and other venomous
animals is that we sampling the genetic
blueprint of their toxins because it
doesn't matter how great technology we
have in the lab what kind of
cutting-edge instruments and and
scientists working in my group I need to
come to the nature and extract the
genetic blueprint of their toxins which
we take back to the lab so how we do
that with we don't kill the snakes we
don't take it back to the lab but we
take a tiny amount of tissue sample and
from that tissue we put it in a in a
small tube with some kind of liquid
which makes it to last for a couple of
weeks comes back to the lab in the lab
we extract the DNA the genetic blueprint
or off of everything and from the DNA
sequence we fish out the toxin genes and
now we have that blueprint of the toxins
and then comes bioinformatics in the
computer we design the largest toxin
libraries literal like a million two
million and more toxin variants in this
library and the screen which one out of
those million strong library is best
targeting for a receptor which could be
used to take a disease under control so
yeah it's really fascinating the whole
research is based on the wisdom of
nature as you know I joke it that you
know we we we utilize nature's wisdom
here and and this is tied to
biodiversity title conservation
absolutely and it's yeah I mean the
applications of it is incredible and can
connect treat or be for a variety of
medicines you mentioned the huge variety
of toxins but are we talking everything
from you know cancer to all to all types
of diseases
that's correct because again so I keep
coming back how many different venomous
animals are in the world like snakes
spiders scorpions lizards lots of marine
creatures and they all live in a
different environment but what they need
immobilize and kill prey and predator as
quickly as possible so the venom is a
mixture of let's say fifty a hundred
different toxins so imagine you have
this many different animals living from
Congo to the Himalaya from from
Polynesia to to the Sahara today toxins
target a little bit different receptors
everywhere so that's why I have this
huge diversity and that's good for for
medicine and and and and and and
research because that means that all of
them is a little bit different they
target a little bit different receptor
you know they have a little bit
different action and that's just like a
huge goldmine for medicine many
different stages to your job right now
it's it's we were discussing what kind
of medications are in clinic I mean
clinical use at this moment but there
are other medications on the pipeline so
in clinical trials there are medications
from animal venom from a shrew venom
actually for cancer there is another one
from a sea anemone been around for
Ottoman disorders there is other one for
heart failure from the Black Mamba venom
Wow
yes a real variety then gosh that's
absolute incredible and you your job I
mean it's many different faces doesn't
it really from being in the lab to being
out in the field I can see from where
you are currently you'll sat on a lot of
kids and I was wondering if you've got
anything in there that you could show us
a little bit more to tell us more about
how you would actually go about taking
those tissue samples so all of these
cases normally it just makes me possible
to to camp out so I have food I have
sleeping bags and equipments you know I
I like to take pictures this is the this
is the this is actually the key to
samples I'm saying so it's a small case
and it's it's very low-tech so it
doesn't it
things cannot go wrong easily I have
different solutions yeah because I just
and needles so I get the snake what if I
get a tissue sample from a snake I got
the snake I put the snake head into a
tube so these are deadly snakes and I
don't want to get bitten so I just slide
the snake head into a tube no I can
safely handle the snake yeah and I get
you know one of these one of these
needles and that ends up directly to the
heart it's completely fine this is this
is how the the vets are doing if they
sampling blood from a snake then I get a
couple drops of blood directly from the
snake because from that blood you can
extract the DNA genetic group in so this
is what we're taking back the snake is
of course it doesn't hurt that snake
that process it's not going to die we
just released a snake and be coming back
with with two small tubes small tubes
each each of them containing some tissue
sample from snakes spiders scorpions you
name it yeah that's fantastic and and I
because I was quite interested to know
actually how you take those samples so
yeah I mean gosh what is your problem
the biggest problem in the samples is
that biggest hurdle is of course we need
permits so you cannot just show up in in
Vietnam and say okay I'm gonna start
catching snakes and bring their samples
out which is completely normal but in
some instances you know it takes like a
year or two to get the permits you need
a permit to catch a snake and you need a
permit to take out the tissue sample
from the country and you know sometimes
to export export from the country and to
import to your destination yeah and
what's your next big project where are
you heading to next or what venomous
species are you going to find well who
knows in the current situation but - hmm
I have pending I have projects which are
on hold for us to the Sahara northern
Congo Sudan and Pakistan and what will
you be seeing in Sudan I have interest
as I mentioned we will look for anything
but anything which has man oh we catch
it right now bit we target we target
which I can say publicly we target those
species which has potassium channel
blocking toxins those species which
blocks a sodium channel because we have
a project on chronic pain okay
and so pain and there's a couple of
other talks with target yeah fantastic
now and just before we get on scoop
we've already got questions flooding in
and I'll get to those very shortly but
just before we do um I kind of covered
obviously the fantastic applications of
your research and why it's so important
but the other side of it I guess is this
side that people mostly associate with
venom is that it is deadly so can we
talk a little bit about the different
types of the venom you know they're in a
jellyfish house in a matter cyst how
does that work compared to like a snake
or compared to a scorpion let's start
with jellyfish I mean you've studied
jellyfish before yeah so basically what
we did you know my Berkut jellyfish is
limit in some sense is limited but on
another sense is quite extensive because
we happened to make the largest toxin
library coming from that group of any
masks in the area where the jellyfish is
is is belonging to so we made a library
of I think 1.5 million toxins and that
library successfully yield that novell
toxins for for ion channels which didn't
have a ligand a Zygon is another
molecule we specifically recognized
those receptors but basically the major
difference between jellyfish that you
have lots of small stinging cells and
you know that's that gets around your
body you know like millions of those
stinging cells and that's how the venom
gets into you in a snake you have two
fangs
and those gonna inject you like a
spoonful of amount of venom one of the
snake which has the largest amount of
venom is the gaboon viper and let me
tell you a story I was done in Congo
having my siesta in the afternoon and
the bulk of pygmies I mentioned earlier
they run up to you at a lab to me I'm
sorry and I say sortin come quickly
and that's it what the hell is cocoa
poopoo you know what's Coco Coco Coco
poopoo is the coolest snake in the world
the gaboon viper so we were running like
I said Coco Papa reloj go boom Viper was
running into the rainforest deep and
then we stopped I said there is it and I
was catching snakes since high school so
I seen a couple snake and I said where
the hell is it and then I saw it it was
so common flashed and we digged out from
the leaf litter in the fray it's just
like huge kaboom Viper was so big that I
could not fit the snake head into the
tubes what I had with me so what I tried
I get the water bottle cut off the head
the top of the water bottle and tried to
put the snake head into the water bottle
it will not fit it was all bid so what I
had to do I actually and don't do this
one at home but what I did is actually
hold the snake right behind the head and
was just sitting on it like a cowboy you
know run in riding a horse to restrain
the gaboon viper and my helper who used
to be elephant poacher but no he reborn
and works for the National fork he cut a
small amount of tissue from the end of
the tail of the snake because it was so
big this is you know tiny stinging cells
you know two to a spoon full amount of
venom which is injected by a five
centimeter two inches long thanks into
your body so it varies quite in a wide
range and what the venom does so the
function of the venom is to kill you or
amoeba lies you as quickly as possible
because either the snake or other
creature wants to eat you or wants to be
protected from you so why would I do it
that the best way to do this one is to
shut down the nervous system shut down
the system the how the nerve cells
communicating with the muscle cells to
contract because you immobilize you get
immobilized the second way you shut down
the circulation so venom gets injected
your whole blood just
you know it gets its coagulated and and
this again as I mentioned it's not one
toxin it's like fifty a hundred or
sometimes more toxins working
synergistically in a venom hand in hand
in a venom just to kill you this is what
happens in your body how many times I
get discussion how how soon the venom
starts to act once you get better and
the venom starts to act right away the
moment it gets injected and Francie's
target it drives away how soon you will
see the clinical symptoms of their bite
that depends on many factors
how much madam has been injected
injected about what kind of snakes was
responsible for the bite are you a kid
or a larger adult in many many factors
example I was in via work a lot in
Vietnam and in the rainy season which is
coming up you know soon or you go to a
hospital and you see patients next to
patients by snake bitten by snakes yeah
you know respiratory paralysis hmm
they've been bitten by a crate crate is
the deadlier version of the Cobra and
there's no anti-venom in Vietnam so they
paralyze they cannot breed their own
they cannot move any any of any of the
Linear's nothing
motionless is just absolutely terrifying
to see the completely conscious that can
hear what you say that they aware of
their surrounding but they can
communicate yeah actually that was one
example when I was seeing these patients
and I said well you know I'm a scientist
I had the international connection so I
called up my body who is a was the
hunger and ambassador or to Thailand and
I said dude do you have 600 euro on you
because can you just go buy an
anti-venom in Thailand we find a
Vietnamese airline pilot who was I said
I connected them so he tried to bring it
to Hanoi first it was rejected because
it was liquid but the second pilot we
find was it's a little bit more
inventive so he was able to bring the
liquid anti-venom to Hanoi we gave it to
the patient
Safety's lives I have tears in my eyes I
was so happy you know Neil applications
just incredible so from one extreme to
another
hey it's all time we've got questions
flooding in so we're gonna get to a few
those and now thank you all for your
questions if you're watching live well
incredible talk this is baby I'm just so
overcome with the inspiration so first
one are the sea snakes um dumped in the
water wave to catch poisonous this is an
important question isn't it all times
yeah it's well we only we only deal with
venomous snakes and I want to make a
difference between poison and venom and
the short answer oh the short
explanation poison you have to lick it
ban on you have to be stung by one of
the definition of the venom that it has
to be delivered by a physical trauma
like a fang oh we seem to have lost
sound on zoltán double get him back oh
he's back he's back there we go yeah and
I think a lot of people are confused
between poisonous and venomous but so
there you go everyone and however that
being said was that sea snake venomous I
think some pictures for you guys and
it's only one of them is I think
non-venomous snakes a boa constrictor
because I was just so happy to find one
just for I can relax myself although I
think I will be also allergic to their
to the abide of the non-venomous snakes
because the saliva and the venom it's is
there is an overlap okay and lots of
questions
does venom help cure cancer you've
touched on this already tell us so there
is no cancer treating venom talked seen
in clinical approval Reiner but at least
there are two toxins which are in
clinical trials for cancer one of them I
mentioned it's coming from a shrew venom
and I think it's from a very cancer and
the second one is coming from a scorpion
toxin where this toxin helps to deliver
a
a huge molecular complex to target
cancer cells and kill them so these are
two in clinical trials and hopefully
they will work absolutely fantastic and
how do you identify a venomous snake
from a non-venomous snake interesting
question no just getting salt turns them
sound back okay because for four weeks
in the middle of the almost zone so I'm
not aware of happening and it's actually
good because I'm not disturbed by all of
those emails but the venomous snakes and
non-venomous snakes the major difference
is they have fangs
so if you want to be really sure you
know what's happening then you catch the
snake you open them out and see their
fangs but of course only if you an
expert the herpetologist you should do
this one but most of the other cases
you're able to take a look based on
their own they're on the core the
pattern that the size of the snake or
the shape of the snake you teleport
which one is venomous and which one is
non-venomous snake yes sometimes it's
much more trickier or you really have to
pick up the snake and you know in order
to identify two different snake species
most most of the times people who rely
on their own their pattern and then a
number of scales covering the snake and
so that's that's how you how you say
characteristic if you don't know you
always do treat every snake as a
venomous so don't don't suspect that
this is okay a non-venomous and if you
see a venomous snake do not panic all
you have to do one two three steps
backward you take a picture and of the
story and you're in a large arc you know
you can just keep keep going if you ever
get bitten in the field the best first
aid is the mobile phone that's the best
first date for Sigma you call for help
as soon as possible for the hospital the
hospital as quickly as possible
Hospital yeah and leave it leave it up
to the experts there at any handling or
any any going nearer absolutely and can
you explain why some snakes pit
interesting question Weiss I'm sick spit
spit there again I think I'm Adam yeah I
have a good story so I I was I was
trying to photograph mambas Mambo Mambo
small green worm was hatching from the
egg okay I was in Europe and my friends
in South Africa call me Zoltan you again
on sound so happens when you come live
from the beautiful meadow back you know
do so that called me for my colleagues
in from southern the numbers are
hatching or about to hatch so I sat on a
plane like little eyes I heard this one
in the morning and in like in afternoon
I was on a plane heading to South Africa
unfortunately a long bus didn't hatch
but we had spitting cobras so we were we
were photographing spitting cobras and I
was asking them so guys how we stand
with water because the best first aid
for spitting cobra spot is lots of water
I said we have none so we were actually
photographing spitting cobras meat
having zero water around us and so you
have to be careful because if the venom
gets spot into your eyes and it can
cause trouble so I don't know that the
gentleman but somebody who I a friend of
Mines friend was actually died from a
spitting cobra spot it's it's their
evolutionary history you know behind so
they can speed the venom you find
spitting cobras in Africa and a couple
of them are spitting in Asia but they
still can deliver the venom by bad so
yeah it's the sort of double w dangerous
yeah
great wall of defense you know being
able to project that venom
really good question really good
questions today I think you'll agree and
how do you get samples from spiders
response spiders
it's again so it if there's two two ways
we aim for any kind of tissue because
all of the body cells contains DNA and
some of them easier to handle some of
them not so whatever we can get
sometimes we have to get the venom gland
and if you have to get the venom gland
we have to unfortunately euthanize the
animal but so either we go for the venom
gland or any piece of tissue for example
from snakes I mentioned the blood but
you can get even DNA sample from a shed
piece of skin so any tissue just like in
humans you know any tissue you can get
the DNA fantastic and another good
question do neurotoxic animals
contribute to studies for diseases like
multiple sclerosis so multiple sclerosis
is a out immune disorder and in
autoimmune disorder the there is a
receptor or you know which is
responsible for we couldn't validate
that target it's it's on immune cells
and if you can block those receptor
specifically then the understanding is
that you can sort of ease the symptoms
of the disease so we usually come up
with a couple molecules from scorpion
toxin library you know which targets
this receptor and it's it's it could be
potentially used in autoimmune disorders
but to develop a drug from toxins to to
have the approval dog
I tell you real-life examples I think it
was from 7 to 24 years or something like
in that magnitude so it's a huge long
process the average to develop a drug is
approximately in ten years so this is
not like a it doesn't work like that
rest behind the snake and then two
months later I have a drug right I wish
it would be that easy yes
and I guess kind of twofolds that the
toxins are really complex also the
disease's themselves are really complex
and fascinating stuff and got a question
here and we're actually running out of
time but um so does that mean a venomous
animal from one region is more effective
treating disease from that same region
that's interesting so because there's so
much diversity of animal species and and
toxins nobody really knows that which
one is good so leading heart attack
medications used all over the world it's
coming from the pygmy rattlesnake venom
a snake which is not really toxic I mean
don't get bitten you have to treat all
venomous animals as potentially can kill
you
but it's still in a pygmy rattlesnake in
in Florida and in the southeast us it's
not really like it's not considered like
a really deadly snake but still that
snake venom gave us one of the major
heart attack medications or the Gila
monster venom from Arizona again it's
the Gila monster if somebody gets bitten
by a Gila monster chances you're gonna
die it's it's very sly it's very slim
very many more don't get bitten because
you could die from it but that venom oh
it's the meadow vikon I'm guessing it's
causing issues with our sound hopefully
we'll get salt on back just in a moment
but this is part of it guys this is what
happens when you have a live in the
field now can't hey it's Alton right
wiles Alton gets his audio back I mean
thank you all for your questions firstly
because they are actually incredible and
what a fascinating topic you know
thinking not only about the pale or a
venom and how we know it so well in the
natural world in terms of it being
deadly and you know so efficient and how
it kills but then how we can use it to
save lives I bet you guys didn't think
about that and it's something that I
think to the general public is often
overlooked but of course scientist
biomedical scientists like Zoltan they
really use that kind of knowledge and
expertise to be able to apply it to our
world and in
waise it's just kind of unfathomable
this is all time how you doing with the
audio hopefully we can get here okay
back back back
ready this is so good cuz we have still
a few more questions but you you were
saying gone and I guess to kind of
summarize that it's not limited to
geographical location is it for example
in Sudan you wouldn't have a lots of
species with venom that is good for
disease compared to somewhere else yeah
so it's it's I mentioned the example
that that major heart attack medication
and the diabetes medication come from a
snake which is not very toxic because
most people would sing the more toxic
snake is better science though that
doesn't work like and it's similar to
geographical distribution nobody knows
really where you would find that
particular toxin which targets that
receptor now if you know that you you're
looking for targeting a potassium
channel and you know which kind of
enemas then to have potassium channel
blocking toxins in their venom then you
can go to those places let's say we
broke lot with scorpion toxins and you
know for scorpions you don't go to
Scandinavia you go to the Sahara you go
to to Asia right yeah totally
that's fantastic okay one more question
is there any reference guide you
recommend in spotting dangerous
creatures for travelers and maybe you
can recommend you know venomous species
or some of your favorite places that you
be so like I like a great guy that you
could recommend or you know a potential
book for or just kind of top tips for
actually spotting these venomous species
if you're out and about well if you go
to a new location let's say you go to
how to Australia South Africa or or
India I would just recommend to buy it
it's hard because there are many books
which are saying venomous animals of of
Cameroon so there are snakes of of
Cameroon and snakes of East Africa
East Africa but like which covers all of
the venomous animals is not that easy to
find for Southwest us Arizona and and
and in neighboring states for Australia
yes you have plenty of books like that
so I I would just research the Internet
venomous creatures and wherever you go
and and but don't be afraid you know the
chances of somebody get bitten or stung
by a scorpion snakes jellyfish it's not
impossible or not zero but it's
extremely minimal you know if you're not
chasing them if you if you're unlucky
just go to the dock use your mobile
phone and go to the doctors as soon as
possible there we are from zoltán to
catch himself and I will also say if you
are heading out in these environments
get to know all the animals non-venomous
and venomous just to to give yourself a
good idea of that environment it's
awesome this has been an absolute joy
thank you ever so much for coming on
live thank you very much yeah you've
been fantastic and this has been so
fascinating and of course thank you all
for tuning in live today we we powered
through just the minor technical issues
there but remember Zoltan is coming to
us live from in the field with the
beautiful meadow Viper so again thank
you all for watching and we'll see you
again next week here on the channel bye